لو تقترب الكاميرا اكثر تحكي لنا بس انتم
اول اتعرف عليك عبد الاله طاهر من اليمن
اهلا وسهلا فيك كم عائلي
والله لنا اربعه اشخاص من هم زوجه ابن
خالي
واختها
وولدها وبنتها بنتها عمرها سنه عمرها سنه
نعم في اي بناء في
البناء اللي هنا
وقربوا يوصلون
للضحايا قربوا الانجاز الله يعطيهم
العافيه امين يا رب ايش طمنوكم في اصوات
من هناك تصدر في اشي في اي بشائر بانهم
احياء والله لا نعلم لا احنا ولا اهم ولكن
عمليه الانقاذ 24 ساعه
شغالين الله يعطيهم العافيه الحمد لله على
كل حال طيب سمعت انه في حدا من العائله
جسده واضح او مبين صح اطراف من الجسم نعم
امين كم عمره
17 سنه يعني هو توفى
تاكدت وفاه الله يرحمه وعزائنا لكم الحمد
لله في عائلات كثيره تحت هذا المبنى نعم
نعم في عائلتك كثيره والحمد لله وزي ما
تشوفون ما بيدنا شيء وعمليه الانجاز 24
ساعه الله يعطيهم العافيه ما قصروا كل شيء
موفرينه كل الخدمات موفره وهذا امر الله
طبعا والنعم بالله طبعا انتم متواجدين من
اول لحظه يعني
مره ثانيه الاب اب الاسره لم يكن موجود صح
لا كان في اضنه كان في مدينه اضنه لحظه
وقوع لحظه وقوع الزلزال طبعا الزلزال
عندنا وهنا بس عندنا الاضرار اخف
فاجينا لهنا الحمد لله هذا يعني نعزيكم
بمن تاكدت وفاته ونتامل انه البقيه يكونوا
على قيد الحياه ان شاء الله يعني طب انتم
اين تباتون تباتون هنا يعني متواصلين في
البقاء هون نعم نعم في سياراتكم سياراتنا
ومنتظرين الى ان الله يفرج علينا ان شاء
الله يفرجها قريبا ان شاء الله